la séance est reprise madame la ministre
mes chers collègues j'informe le Sénat
que des candidatures pour sierger au
sein de la CMP chargée d'élaborer un
texte sur la proposition de loi visa à
ouvrir le tiers financement à l'état à
ses établissements publics et aux
collectivités territoriales pour
favoriser les travaux de rénovation
énergétique ont été publiés ces
candidatures seront ratifiés si la
présidence n'a pas reçu d'opposition
dans le délai d'une heure prévue par
notre règlement
j'informe le Sénat qu'une candidature
pour siéger au sein de la commission des
affaires européennes a été publiée cette
candidature sera ratifiée si la
présidence n'a pas reçu d'opposition
dans le délai d'une heure prévue par
notre règlement
l'ordre du jour appelle la désignation
des 19 membres de la commission
d'enquête sur l'utilisation du réseau
social Tik Tok son exploitation des
données sa stratégie d'influence en
application de l'article 8 ter alinéa 5
de notre règlement les listes des
candidats présentées par les groupes ont
été publiés ces candidatures seront
ratifiées si la présidence ne reçoit pas
d'opposition dans le délai d'une heure
prévue par notre règlement
l'ordre du jour appelle le débat
d'actualité dans le thème sur la
proposition du président du Sénat après
concertation avec les groupes elle
suivant les conséquences de l'inflation
sur le pouvoir d'achat des Français
dans ce débat le gouvernement aura la
faculté si le juge nécessaire de prendre
la parole immédiatement après chaque
orateur pour une durée de 2 minutes
l'orateur disposera alors à son tour du
droit de répartie pour une minute le
temps de réponse du gouvernement à
l'issue du débat est limité à 5 minutes
madame la ministre vous pourrez donc si
vous le souhaitez répondre après chaque
orateur une fois que celui-ci aura
retrouvé une place dans l'émission
dans le débat la parole est à Monsieur
Stéphane Ravier pour les non inscrits
pour 3 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame le ministre
mes chers collègues depuis janvier 2021
les Français font face à une hausse de
prix généralisée et inédite depuis 40
ans elle est principalement dû aux
restrictions d'activités de la période
covid combinée à de fortes dépendances
en matière première et produit
manufacturés en provenance de payer
étrangers en vérité la guerre en Ukraine
n'a fait que renforcer un phénomène
d'inflation déjà bien installé les
Français ont désormais une certitude
l'affaiblissement de l'État stratège est
souverain voulu par votre gouvernement
nous conduit à l'appauvrissement
actuelle selon l'Insee l'inflation
accélère à 6,2% en février sur les 12
derniers mois avec plus 14,5% dans
l'alimentation et plus 14% des prix de
l'énergie de plus en plus de stations
services affichent le prix des
carburants quels qu'ils soient à plus de
2 euros le litre aujourd'hui un kilo de
pommes de terre noisettes surgelés coûte
2,19 en février 2022 il coûtait 1,05
sont une augmentation de 108%. le prix
de la crème fraîche fouettée a augmenté
de 40% en rayon
210 g d'émmental rampés coûtait 1,65 en
février 2022 il coûte 2,19 aujourd'hui
sont une hausse de
33%. le chariot des courses des classes
populaires et de plus en plus réduit la
demande au resto du coeur a augmenté de
12 % cette année les Banques
Alimentaires révèlent aider 2 millions
400000 personnes soit 3 fois plus qu'en
20001 dans la sixième puissance
économique du monde que la France des
millions de personnes ne mangent plus à
leur faim ne se chauffent plus ne se
soigne plus c'est le grand effondrement
des classes populaires qu'une fiscalité
toujours très importante accompagne dans
l'affaissement de la classe moyenne
française la fiscalité est un vrai sujet
pour le pouvoir d'achat des Français
quand on sait que 60% du prix de
l'essence ne sont que des taxes qui
alimentaient les caisses percées de
l'État l'urgence est de remettre à
produire en France pour permettre la
création d'emplois et donc de salaire
une fiscalité saine pour une fine et
retrouver la croissance mais même après
avoir éteint la lumière de leur domicile
BC couper le chauffage sacrifier le
renouvellement de leur garde-robe et une
partie du contenu de leur réfrigérateur
les ménages les retraités les étudiants
ne voient toujours pas le bout du tunnel
inflationniste vous annonces et
prévisions sont toutes se sont toutes
révélées fausses le ministre de
l'économie avait promis l'effondrement à
venir de l'économie russe suite au
sanctions au printemps 2022 résultat en
2023 le FMI révèle la très bonne santé
économique de la Russie pendant que la
nôtre prend l'eau de toute part monsieur
Véran véritable boussole qui indique le
sud annoncé au mois d'août dernier que
nous avions atteint le pic de
l'inflation alors que les prix n'ont
cessé d'augmenter depuis madame la
ministre qu'attendez-vous donc pour
sortir du marché européen de
l'électricité et de la reine
renucléarisées relocaliser baisser la
fiscalité les cotisations patronales sur
les salaires
merci
la ministre non non la parole est
maintenant au président Jean-Claude
Roquier pour le groupe RDSE pour 5
minutes
j'ai le président de la ministre mes
chers collègues
entendre les préoccupations de nos
concitoyens dans les territoires ou
celles des professionnels
présents en ce moment au sol de
l'agriculture se débat sur les
conséquences de l'inflation et peut-être
encore plus d'actualité que celui des
retraites le retour d'une forte des prix
à la consommation courante pour aller
alimentaire pour entretien matériaux
divers équipements de construction
privée est un tournant majeur de la
pré-coïde si le choc de la guerre
Ukraine et les sanctions contre la
Russie ont eu un effet indéniable sur
les prix de l'énergie la remontée des
prix avaitéralité commencé dès 2021 au
moment des premiers déconfinement
elle s'explique en particulier par
l'augmentation du coût des matières
premières et des transports notamment du
fret maritime avec des marchandises en
grande partie importée des étrangers
souvent en Europe nous commençons
peut-être à payer le prix de la deuxième
industrialisation et de la petite et la
perte subordonnée économique le débat
sur le niveau de l'inflation n'est pas
nouveau on observe souvent un décalage
entre l'indice synthétique et des prix
la consommation tel qu'il est mesuré par
l'INSEE et l'inflation observée ou
ressenti par les consommateurs qui
dépend de son niveau de revenus de son
lieu de résidence de ces préférences et
de ces contraintes personnelles par
ailleurs l'indice des prix la
consommation ne donne pas une mesure
complète du coup du coup de la vie
d'autres données Lopez lourdement sur le
budget ménage comme le prix des
logements que les statisticiens
intègrent l'indice pondéré des loyers de
façon générale les prix des actifs
mobiliers ou immobiliers
ont beaucoup augmenté ces dernières
années l'injonction massive de liquidité
par les banques centrales
entraîner une forte inflation des
valeurs mobilières sur une longue
période mais qui n'avait pas eu d'impact
sur les prix alors que consommation le
taux d'inflation courante est élu aussi
rester faible voire nulle pendant les
décennies à peine à tenir à peine
atteignent-ils l'objectif de 2% fixé par
la Banque centrale européenne
l'inflation et longtemps restée un
souvenir en montant aux années 70 80
soit le fait de payer en développement
comme la Turquie l'Iran enlever les yeux
là où l'Argentine aujourd'hui elle
touche à nouveau l'ensemble des pays
développés peut-être à quelle question
près à quelques exceptions près comme le
Japon
les conséquences de cette inflation sont
à la fois massives et inégales une
baisse du pouvoir d'achat des ménages et
une érosion de l'épargne mais qui
dépendent beaucoup de la part de chaque
poste de départ dans le budget indiqué
le Déménage inversement l'inflation peut
aussi réduire le coût de net pensons à
70 ou l'inflation une drogue douce qui
disait à l'époque profiter aux
emprunteurs et défavoriser les épargnes
dans tous les cas une mobilise elle
modifie en profondeur les anticipations
des agents économiques et rend les
prévisions plus aléatoires le pire des
scénario serait la preuve poursuite
d'une forte inflation avec une
croissante déclinique faible ou nulle le
retour de ce qu'on appelle la
staturation face à la complicité des
calculs d'inflation et du poids d'achat
des indices alternatifs puis parlant ont
été élaborés d'abord l'indice Big Mac
aux États-Unis ensuite jambon beurre
plus français
perçue qui intègre des paramètres plus
individuels et subjectif dernièrement
l'agence Bloomberg a créé un indice
corporé
qui intègre le prix des ingrédients
nécessaires à la préparation de ce plat
traditionnel sur un an il augmentait non
pas de 6% comme l'indice synthétique et
les prix mais de près de 15%. si les
prix de l'ensemble des produits de
consommation 120 se stabiliser se
déplaudit alimentaires or eux fortement
augmenté depuis l'été 2022 c'est dans ce
contexte tendu que devrait aboutir au
plus tard aujourd'hui les négociations
commerciales en te fournisseur et
distributeur de produits de grande
consommation à propos desquels le Sénat
a adopté une importance une importante
pour position de loi il y a deux
semaines
des questions de la ministre en
conclusion de mon propos pendant ce défi
de l'inflation le gouvernement privatif
des mesures supplémentaires en faveur du
pouvoir d'achat en plus des nombreuses
initiatives qui l'a déjà prises depuis
un an et demi et qui collait des forces
d'une diverses même si elle contribue
plus qu'ailleurs à atténuer les effets
de l'inflation sur les ménages et enfin
dans son panier indien anti-inflation le
gouvernement envisage-t-il aussi de
mettre la contribution les entreprises
en particulier celles qui ont largement
bénéficié d'aide publique ces dernières
années
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre
merci bien sûr
merci Monsieur le
président monsieur le sénateur
je m'appelle à répondre à vos questions
parce que j'ai pas grand chose à
remettre en question dans vos propos ni
d'ailleurs sur l'indice un peu macro qui
est porté par l'INSEE ni sur ce que vous
avez dit sur la l'inflation ressentie
qui me semble être la boussole la plus
importante à suivre vous dire quand même
que la progression en matière
d'inflation
elle est réelle et je ne la renie en
rien le gouvernement non plus on est à
6,2% sur un an et on est très clairement
avec une accélération de la poussière
inflationniste en matière alimentaire
vous l'avez vu hier les chiffres sont
sortis plus 14,5% d'inflation en février
après plus 13% en janvier pour autant si
cette inflation est demeure soutenue
l'Insee constate aussi que la croissance
a été positive au quatrième trimestre et
que malgré tout fruit aussi des mesures
prises par le gouvernement le pouvoir
d'achat au quatrième trimestre pouvoir
d'achat nos concitoyens n'a pas chuté
n'a pas été morcelé n'a pas sombré
pourquoi
parce que les prélèvements obligatoires
et notamment fiscaux continuent à
diminuer c'est l'effet aussi de la
suppression de la redevance télé c'est
l'effet de la troisième tranche de la
suppression de taxe d'habitation mais
aussi grâce à une politique très
volontaire en matière d'emploi vous le
savez et au versement particulièrement
élevé dixit
de la prime partage de la valeur c'est
plus d'un milliard d'euros pour aller
vite qui ont été distribués à un million
de salariés en moyenne 1000 euros par
salarié donc le pouvoir d'achat se
maintient malgré cette inflation
soutenue vous m'avez posé une question
très très claire j'y réponds aussi
clairement le gouvernement a beaucoup
fait le gouvernement continue à faire en
sorte que nous partageions les efforts
l'État a fait beaucoup les Français font
beaucoup nous demandons le président de
la République on chef la première
ministre et Bruno Le Maire aussi et
votre modeste serviteur est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui les distributeurs
notamment essaye de contribuer à
l'effort en essayant de faire des
opérations qui puissent permettre en
prenant sur leur marge et non pas sur
celle de nos pro ducteurs qui puissent
permettre de limiter l'inflation
alimentaire le plus possible ok nous
sommes donc toujours en poursuite de
négociation sur ce sujet merci madame la
ministre monsieur le Président roquet
pas de réponse la parole est maintenant
présidentielle babarie pour 7 minutes
pour le groupe les républicain
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
monsieur Colin
la guerre en Ukraine depuis le 24
février 2022 c'est conséquences sur les
prix des matières premières a servi de
catalyseur à de profonds bouleversements
économiques le premier d'entre eux et le
retour de l'inflation qui avait
pratiquement disparu depuis plus de 20
ans
la crise de la covid puis l'apparition
de nombreux goulots d'étranglement au
niveau des chaînes de production avaient
déjà entamé les vertus d'un commerce
mondial libéral fonctionnant en grande
partie sur la base d'une énergie à bas
coût même si certains économistes
envisagaient en 2022 une reprise modérée
de l'inflation le retour de cette
dernière a des niveaux jamais vu depuis
50 ans a surpris tous les spécialistes
en effet
l'affaiblissement croissant de la
conjoncture mondiale une mondialisation
permettant de baisser les coûts de
production notamment en Asie et
l'abondance des matières premières
énergétiques bon marché ont fixé
durablement l'inflation sous la barre
des 2%
la sortie de la crise sanitaire de 2020
a généré une demande soutenue de la part
des ménages désireux de pouvoir enfin
consommer après des semaines de
confinement les prix de nombreux
produits ont ainsi augmentés face à une
production insuffisante des organisée il
y a des difficultés de transport mais
c'est surtout la guerre en Europe de
l'Est qui a perturbé la cheminement de
matières premières énergétique
industrielle et alimentaire en réponse
aux sanctions occidentales les Russes
sont sensiblement réduits leur
exportation de gaz en direction des
Européens jusqu'à les arrêter ils sont
suivis une forte hausse des cours du
pétrole et surtout du gaz européen qui a
généré une flambée de l'inflation cette
dernière ainsi atteint plus de 10% en
zone euro mettant sous pression pouvoir
d'achat des ménages entraînant
logiquement une baisse de la
consommation la guerre en Ukraine n'a
pas provoqué l'inflation elle l'a
renforcé et accélérée
paradoxalement l'inflation a dopé la
croissance du chiffre d'affaires des
principaux groupes français du CAC 40
qui affiche plus de 140 milliards
d'euros de résultat net cumulés
ces résultats s'expliquent par des
montées en gamme des plans d'économie
mais aussi et surtout par le fait que la
très grande majorité a pu répercuter
dans ses prix la flambée des coûts tel
n'a en revanche pas été le cas de très
nombreux ETI et PME consommatrice
d'énergie dans le domaine industriel
agricole et artisanal le cas bien
concret des nombreuses fermetures de
boulangerie en est le meilleur exemple
madame la ministre pourquoi ne pas avoir
supprimé le critère lié à la puissance
installée permettant de bénéficier des
tarifs réglementés de vente
d'électricité les fameux 36 kVA
en début de semaine les ministres
européens l'énergie se sont retrouvés à
Stockholm madame la ministre où en est
la réforme du marché européen de
l'énergie qui avait été annoncée pour la
fin de l'année 2022 a-t-on enfin obtenu
le découplage du prix d'électricité et
du gaz
combiné à l'augmentation du prix de
l'énergie l'inflation des prix des
produits de grande consommation en plus
significativement le pouvoir d'achat des
Français de 5% l'été dernier l'inflation
des prix à la consommation sur un an
établit aujourd'hui à 6,2 % à cette
crise du pouvoir d'achat s'ajoute une
crise sociale voire sociétale selon une
étude publiée ce lundi
2,4 millions de personnes bénéficiaient
de l'aide alimentaire fin 2022 soit
trois fois plus qu'il y a 10 ans en ce
début d'année plus d'un tiers des
personnes accueillies sont des nouveaux
bénéficiaires
dès juillet 2022 notre collègue
présidente de la commission des affaires
économiques Sophie prima vous enjoignez
de cesser cette politique de chèques
dispendieuse et éphémère et d'engager
une politique ferme de revalorisation du
travail et notamment de la
défiscalisation et désocialisation des
heures supplémentaires
l'exercice était certes difficile mais
faute d'anticipation et d'évaluation
suffisante la loi pouvoir d'achat n'a eu
qu'un effet pansement moyennant un coup
non négligeable pour nous finances
publiques les prix des produits
alimentaires ont bondi de
14,5% sur un an
la confiance des ménages est dégradée
mais le taux d'épargne qui s'établit à
16,6% du revenu brut selon France
stratégie les conséquences de la crise
varient selon le profil des ménages les
personnes âgées éloignés des
centres-villes étant particulièrement
exposés
alors que les négociations commerciales
entre les industriels et les enseignes
de la grande distribution de sa chèvre
aujourd'hui
on nous annonce un mars rouge
hier devant nos collègues députés Bruno
Le Maire a écarté cette idée et affirmer
que des solutions implicables aux
produits alimentaires étaient à l'étude
plus encore des mesures efficaces et
crédibles devrait nous être présenté
dans quelques jours pourtant la
Fédération du commerce et de la
distribution évoquent une augmentation à
venir de l'ordre de 10%
. et ce matin même en plein salon de
l'agriculture la présidente de la snsea
accuse une partie des distributeurs de
refusés de payer l'intégralité de la
part des agriculteurs les causes de la
crise inflationniste on l'a vu sont
multiples cette crise appelle une
stratégie claire des mesures ciblées et
des investissements longs madame la
ministre quel sera le plan du
gouvernement pour aider les Français à
traverser cette nouvelle crise je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre je vous en prie
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Babarit je ne reviens en rien
sur les causes et merci d'avoir rappelé
aussi la le retour de la demande post
covid qui a contribué à booster
l'inflation avant même la guerre en
Ukraine
d'abord j'ai à cœur de vous répondre sur
le bouclier tarifaire et la question
précise sur les 36 qui le veulent en
paire
vous parlez dans votre conclusion de la
nécessité de cibler les aides et je
connais la sensibilité de la chambre
haute et la vôtre et la mienne à la
dépense publique nous avions face à ce
choix de problématiques nous aurions été
amenés à accompagner des entreprises qui
n'auraient pas eu besoin d'être sous un
bouclier et donc prise en charge et ça
aurait entraîné des dépenses publiques
massives ça se compte ici en milliards
et ça n'aurait pas été idoine on aurait
accompagné des entreprises en amont qui
n'en n'aurait pas forcément eu besoin
par ailleurs je voudrais pas qu'on
oublie si ça pèse si c'était si simple
ça aurait peut-être été fait mais que
pour installer des compteurs ça ne se
fait pas du jour au lendemain et que ça
aurait été de la part des énergéticiens
un certain mais c'est important et je
connais votre sérieux donc en termes de
logistique c'était pas si facile que ça
et ça n'aurait pas été fait du jour au
lendemain donc nous avons choisi de
cibler un amortisseur plus un guichet
qui est assez facile un beau toutes est
disponible et pour les TPE un tarif à
280 euros le mégawattheure lycée sur
l’année 2023 vous
parlez de pansement en matière de
soutien au pouvoir d'achat je voudrais
quand même rappeler l'ampleur du
pansement le bouclier est tarifaire qui
protège nos concitoyens de la hausse des
prix de l'énergie c'est 110 milliards
d'euros de présence de l'État entre
octobre 21 et décembre 2023 110
milliards d'euros c'est un plan de
relance de la consommation à lui tout
seul je voudrais pas qu'on oublie non
plus le paquet pouvoir d'achat avec la
revalorisation des aPL des minima
sociaux la prime de rentrée
exceptionnelle l'adoption du chèque
énergie exceptionnel mais aussi et je le
disais la prime partage de la valeur je
connais votre sensibilité aux
entreprises 300 000 entrepreneurs de not
TPE ont versé plus d'un milliard d'euros
à un million de salariés pour justement
accompagner les salariés dans cette
poussée inflationniste j'ai pas assez de
temps pour les autres questions j'y
répondrai par écrit je vous remercie
merci Madame la Ministre la parole est
maintenant madame Vanina paoliga pour le
groupe les indépendants pour 5 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues avec les
conséquences économiques de la pandémie
les sécheresses et le dérèglement
climatique 2021 réunissait bon nombre de
conditions propices et une inflation
record
l'Ukraine par Poutine encore aggravé
cette situation les prix d'énergie ont
bondit la crise alimentaire est devenue
plus menaçante lorsque les Russes ont
délibérément choisi de bloquer les
exportations ukrainiennes de blé nous
craignons que la fin du quoi qu'il en
coûte apporte son lot de faillite et le
retour de la guerre en Europe dans des
économies déjà très éprouvées par les
confinements ne présagère rien de bon au
cours de la difficile année 2022 les
prix ont augmenté en France de 6,2%.
j'espère ne choquer personne en disant
que ce n'est pas si mal sur la même
année à titre de comparaison l'Argentine
a battu son propre record avec 95%
d'inflation et plus proche de nous le
Royaume-Uni sont global Britain ont
enregistré l'inflation de 11% devant les
États-Unis avec quant à eux 7%. au sein
de l'Union l'inflation moyenne constatée
sur 2022 a été de 10%
avec une guerre à nos portes avec la
raréfaction de notre approvisionnement
en gaz l'envolée du prix des
hydrocarbures avec nombre de nos
centrales à l'arrêt je crois pouvoir
dire que nous en sommes plutôt pas trop
mal tirés bien que quand on se compare
on se console quand on se regarde on se
désole quand même
l'inflation frappe plus fortement les
plus démunis nos concitoyens ce dont le
pouvoir d'achat est fortement contraint
par les dépenses obligatoires les
dépenses courantes ceux-là sont en
grande difficulté les prises
alimentaires ont bondi de 14,5% cela
pèse très lourd dans le budget des
ménages français c'est aussi le cas tout
le monde le sait des prix de
l'électricité avec un mégawattheure qui
est passé de 220 euros en décembre 2021
à 700 euros au cours de l'année 2022 il
est heureusement redescendu depuis mais
malgré le bouclier énergétique la
facture de concitoyens a néanmoins
augmenté de près de 15%
. les prix des carburants ont également
atteints des sommets grevant l'activité
de tous ceux qui travaillent les
artisans les chauffeurs les livreurs et
plus généralement de tous les Français
particulièrement ceux qui vivent en
milieu rural
face à ces augmentations frappant plus
violemment les plus vulnérables d'entre
nous la tentation est grande de recourir
à l'argent public entre la crise de la
covid et les difficultés économiques que
nous rencontrons actuellement notre
dette publique elle aussi s'est envolée
2300 Milliards en 2019 elle a voisine
aujourd'hui 3000 milliards avec la
remontée des taux d'intérêt cet état de
fait est alarmant il est urgent de
renverser la vapeur et de commencer à
réduire notre dette publique mais alors
quelle solution pour améliorer le
pouvoir d'achat de nos concitoyens
j'envoie deux principalement tout
d'abord et au risque de choquer la
sobriété en 2022 année de grandes
tensions énergétique la consommation
électrique de notre pays a nettement
baissé par rapport à 2021 grâce
notamment aux efforts consentis par nos
entreprises et par nos concitoyens à
travers nos éco-gestes nous avons même
réussi à diminuer notre consommation par
rapport à l'année 2020 qui était quand
même marqué par les confinements et où
les gens sont beaucoup restés chez eux
les prix délirants de l'énergie rendent
ainsi bien plus rentable les travaux
d'isolation et les énergies
renouvelables la sobriété présente en
outre l'avantage de ne pas participer à
la spirale inflationniste
la deuxième solution pour le pouvoir
d'achat
c'est le travail les aides
gouvernementales sont toujours prélevés
sur nos concitoyens que ce soit par
l'impôt ou par la dette nous ne devons
jamais l'oublier nous saluons donc les
fins du gouvernement madame la ministre
depuis 2017 pour s'efforcer de réduire
le poids des contributions sur nos
entreprises nos concitoyens nous
souhaitons que cet effort soit poursuivi
notamment sur les impôts de production
il nous faut favoriser les
investissements dans nos territoires
pendant les infrastructures que dans
l'appareil productif le dérèglement
climatique nous exhortait depuis bien
longtemps à changer nos modes de
production la crise que nous traversons
peut-être l'accélérateur de ce
changement
les Chinois désignent par un même mot
crise et opportunité il y a longtemps
que les Français le savent à défaut
d'avoir du pétrole nous nous devons
d'avoir encore des idées et cette
fois-ci des bonnes je vous remercie
merci chers collègues pas de réponse
la parole est donc maintenant monsieur
Paul tout simple paris j pour le groupe
écologiste pour 5 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
les chiffres sont historiques
6,2% d'augmentation des prix à la
consommation sur un an
six derniers mois les structures
alimentaires partenaires du réseau des
Banques alimentaires ont recueilli
entière de personnes en plus
la hausse des prix creusent
dramaticalement les cas entre les
Français qui vous le savez selon leur
revenu mais aussi leur lieu de et
conditions de vie subissent plus ou
moins fortement les conséquences de la
crise qui marginalise et précarise à
vitesse accrue une grande partie de nos
concitoyens à titre d'exemple et selon
les récentes études de l'OFCE et de
France stratégie le choc varie fortement
en fonction du profil des ménages les
personnes âgées pauvres et éloignés des
centres-villes étant plus impactés si
l'inflation moyenne sur l'année 2022 se
situait à 5,2 % elle était de 8,5% pour
les ménages les plus exposés et de 3,4%
pour les moins touchés soit un écart de
5 points en défaveur des plus précaires
cela je le constate chaque jour en Corse
sur mon territoire
majoritairement rurale dont 18% de la
population vit sous le seuil de pauvreté
contre 15% sur le plan national chaque
jour je constate aussi les ravages de la
crise qui accentuent la précarité et
creuse les inégalités car aux
conséquences de la crise s'ajoutent pour
notre territoire le surcoût induit par
l'importation de nouveaux produits et
matières premières face à ce constat
force est de constater que des mesures
apportées par le gouvernement sont à ce
stade insuffisantes et trop ponctuelle
face à une crise qui saracine face à une
précarisation structurelle qui a hélas
contribué à graver en actant de
nombreuses régressions sociales
réforme de l'assurance chômage baisse
des aPL quant aux mesures temporaires
comme la revalidation anticipée des
minima sociaux en deçà de l'inflation
n'apporte aucune solution durable
pire le gouvernement agite et se vantent
de mesurettes à effet d'un moulinet
partant de canicule la création d'un
panier anti-inflation sur une
cinquantaine de produits basés sur le
volontariat nous pouvons que remercier
l'action ambitieuse de ce gouvernement à
la hauteur de ses enjeux cependant en
2021 une étude de l'INSEE d'alimenter à
montrer que 64% des personnes
interrogées expriment de la honte à se
rendre à l'aide alimentaire la création
d'une prime d'alimentation aurait limité
tout est fait de stigmatisation et
laisserait des personnes actrices de
leur alimentation au cours des derniers
mois notre groupe
avait porté plusieurs propositions afin
d'aider les Français face à l'envolée
des prix nous avions proposé des juillet
dernier de protéger les plus précaires
en établissant des mesures visant à
limiter 1% de la hausse des prix des
loyers pour les locataires l'Espagne
elle a suivi cette voie en limitant la
hausse à 2%. nous avons défendu
l'augmentation des salaires notamment du
salaire minimum porté à 1500 euros net
aujourd'hui nous défendons une
augmentation substantielle des minima
sociaux au-delà du seuil de pauvreté
comme l'instauration des revenus minimum
garantis aucune de ces propositions
pourtant efficaces immédiatement et sur
le long terme non trouvé écho du côté du
gouvernement nous ne pouvons que le
regretter enfin j'ajouterai que si
l'inflation actuelle a des origines
conjoncturelles notamment du fait de la
guerre en Ukraine et ses conséquences
quant à la cheminement des produits
agricoles énergétiques nous serions tous
coupables si nous en mettons un facteur
structurel celui de la réification
ressources en effet nombreuses sont les
études scientifiques qui ont directement
liées la baisse des rendements agricoles
ou encore de la production industrielle
avec la hausse des températures le
réchauffement climatique impact donc de
manière durable le coût et les volumes
de production entraînant une hausse
inexorable des prix la Banque centrale
européenne a déjà alerté à plusieurs
reprises sur le sujet la dégradation de
l'environnement associée à la
rééducation des ressources nous expose
donc à une inflation de fonds qui
touchera plusieurs mois les Français les
plus modestes c'est pourquoi nous ne
cesserons de le rappeler il est
aujourd'hui urgent de donner les moyens
à la France de réussir sa transition
écologique et de mettre en place une
économie au service de la construction
de la sobriété aujourd'hui nous sommes
au regret madame la ministre de
constater que le gouvernement n'apporte
aucune solution durable à cette crise
sans précédent qui s'annonce
merci merci chers collègues madame la
ministre
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur Paris
chacun qualifie comme il le veut les
mesures mises en place par le
gouvernement mais je peux pas ne pas
réagir à l'esprit de à l'entendre
surtout de mesurer comme vous l'avez
mentionné
quand on parle de ce que nous faisons
maintenant depuis 2 ans et demi d'abord
vous aurez remarqué que je ne me suis
pas j'ai pas commencé par rappeler les
chiffres de l'inflation et surtout le
fait que effectivement par rapport à
nombre de nos voisins européens on peut
peindre le tableau comme on veut mais la
France s'en sort quand même mieux que
l'ensemble de ses voisins européens et
ça n'est pas le fruit du hasard auquel
je ne crois pas c'est le fruit aussi
d'une politique économique c'est le
fruit d'un combat pour l'emploi c'est le
fruit d'un travail de fond pour faire
baisser les prélèvements obligatoires et
les impôts que payent nos Français
augmenter leur pouvoir d'achat vous
dites mesurer je le redirai autant de
fois qu'il faudra le dire 110 milliards
d'euros de soutien à la demande par le
truchement du bouclier tarifaire pour
nos compatriotes si ça c'est une Durette
alors il faut m'expliquer comment on
forme un budget pour ce qui est juste de
vous fixer une comparaison l'ensemble
des français payent en matière d'impôt
sur le revenu 86 milliards d'euros nous
avons mis plus pour accompagner les
Français durant cette période que ce que
nous récoltons en matière d'impôt sur le
revenu nous avons augmenté les minima
sociaux vous considérez monsieur
parisgiq c'est assez nul ce que nous
avons fait en un mot chacun pense ce
qu'il veut j'ai quand même à coeur de
partager ce que ça donne ça donne pour
un certain nombre de nos compatriotes
des aides allant de 200 de 377 à 416
euros selon les âges et les enfants par
famille pour la location de rentrée
scolaire ça donne aussi un
accompagnement de 687 euros net annuel
pour une secrétaire de mairie avec 15
ans d'ancienneté grâce à l'augmentation
du point d'indice mais aussi un gain de
543 euros net annuels pour un agent
d'accueil en début de carrière par
exemple
dire que ce sont des mesurettes je ne
n'en suis pas d'accord dire que vous
auriez fait autrement c'est le charme de
nos échanges dans la chambre haute je
vous remercie si Monsieur parisji
la parole est maintenant madame Nadège
avait pour le groupe RDPI pour 6 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues pendant plus de 30
ans la hausse durable des prix leur
hausse généralisée à la fois sur les
biens et les services a été contenu en
France la rupture intervenue à l'été
2021 fut soudaine avec des conséquences
négatives sur le pouvoir d'achat des
Françaises et des Français sur le
fonctionnement de nos services publics
de nos entreprises et de nos
collectivités cette rupture fut violente
et en particulier pour les plus modestes
car le renchérissement du coût de la vie
touche avant tout les produits
alimentaires et l'énergie il touche au
fondamentaux de notre vie quotidienne et
c'est par conséquent pour les
responsables publics publics pardon que
nous sommes une préoccupation majeure
d'où la tenue de débat régulier et d'où
notre débat de cet après-midi
les causes sont multiples et de nature
différente certains certaines d'ordre
conjoncturels d'autres plus structurels
un effet cocktail en somme cette
inflation est la conséquence de la
sortie de crise pandémique avec une
demande qui a pu nettement augmenter
plus fortement que l'offre restez
fragile sur certains produits elle est
la résultante de l'agression militaire
russe en Ukraine qui a occasionné une
baisse des exportations et une montée
des prix des matières premières elle est
aussi alimentée par la baisse de l'euro
qui a renchéi les prix des importations
les prix de l'énergie ont aussi été mis
sous pression et l'explication ne réside
pas que dans le contexte international
elle réside aussi dans un fait durable
l'épuisement des sources d'énergie
fossiles couplées avec l'impératif
transition écologique qu'il nous faut
nécessairement mener de front cette
rupture fut et de mort demeure pendant
cependant moins appuyé en France
qu'ailleurs
avec un taux à 6,2% sur un an selon la
dernière note de l'Insee publiée hier la
France reste en dessous de la moyenne de
la zone euro et le pic inflex
inflationniste cela a été dit devrait
être atteint cette année les
explications sont à trouver dans les
politiques mises en œuvre depuis
maintenant plus d'un an contre la
l'inflation l'État a agi il agit et
agira encore nous soutenons toutes vos
actions en effet afin de soutenir le
pouvoir d'achat de nombreuses mesures
ont été adoptées avec la revalorisation
des mini-massociaux des prestations
sociales et familiales de même que des
pensions de retraite de base globalement
les dispositifs de soutien ont porté sur
l'encadrement des prix de l'énergie 12
millions de ménages les plus modestes
ont été destinataires d'un chèque de 100
ou 200 euros en décembre dernier un
chèque exceptionnel a été attribué à ce
chauffant au fioul ou principalement au
bois une action résolue sur le travail
aussi revalorisation du point d'indice
des agents publics la prime Macron
devenue prime pour le partage de la
valeur un dispositif pérenne que les
entreprises peuvent mettre en place
chaque année il a bénéficié à 5,5
millions de salariés en 2022 une
augmentation de 50% par rapport à 2021
et avant tout au sein des petites
entreprises une prime moyenne de 739
euros pour un total de 4,4 milliards
d'euros elle a contribué à préserver le
pouvoir d'achat des ménages en 2022 en
dépit de la hausse des prix l'Insee le
rappel également par ailleurs j'en
profite pour saluer l'accord
intersadical validé par la
CFE-CGC la CFDT FO et la CFTC son
objectif généralisé largement des
dispositifs tels que l'intéressement la
participation et la prime de partage de
la valeur à toutes les entreprises de
plus de 11 employés on avance sur ce
point essentiel je forme le vœu que nous
continuons que nous continuions pardons
à avancer lors de l'examen du texte
plein emploi je pense enfin au projet de
loi énergie adoptée ou en cours de
discussion au Parlement je citais les
derniers chiffres de l'Insee quel est le
constat dans le détail une baisse sur
les coûts de l'énergie 14% sur un an
contre 16,3 en janvier mais une
persistance d'une hausse sur les prix de
l'alimentation et des services alors que
les négociations annuelles entre
distributeurs et industrie
agroalimentaires s'achève les prix dans
les rayons des supermarchés pourraient
encore grimper il est par conséquent
nécessaire madame la ministre qu'une
vigilance particulière soit portée en ce
domaine afin de maîtriser ce que
j'appellerai l'inflation de l'assiette
en visite au salon de l'agriculture
samedi le président de la République
s'est exprimé à destination des pêcheurs
en donnant de la visibilité sur les
aides mais aussi sur la hausse des prix
dans les supermarchés en appelant les
distributeurs à faire un effort sur leur
marge il y a la détermination des
nouvelles mesures adaptées ciblées et
puis il y a je dirais l'optimisation du
recours au dispositif existant un
exemple pour aider les Français modestes
à faire face à la flambée des prix du
carburant le gouvernement a mis en place
une indemnité de 100 euros parce que
plusieurs millions de conducteurs
éligibles ne s'étaient pas encore
manifestées vous avez annoncé la
prolongation du délai de demande jusqu'à
la fin du mois de mars sur les aides
nous devons le faire savoir dans nos
territoires respectifs je voudrais
conclure en soulignant la situation en
outre-mer le ministre jean-François
caranco a présenté en décembre un plan
pour préserver le pouvoir d'achat des
ultramarins fruits d'intenses
négociation se plant traitait
essentiellement de l'élargissement des
boucliers qualité-prix adaptés à chaque
territoire où en est-on de cette
houdinon du pouvoir d'achat à la carte
alors qu'au-delà de cette période
inflationniste la vie chère est un
problème structurel en outre-mer je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice
Nadège avait je suggère si vous
l'autorisez parce que le sujet est trop
important pour que je l'ai Lude de
répondre sur la question ou Dino
outre-mer par écrit après la séance dans
cette émission pour que je sois
parfaitement complète vous m'avez aussi
et en même temps interroger sur la prise
de parole du président de la République
au Salon International de l'Agriculture
samedi matin et les actions qui vont
arriver et que nous appelons de nos vœux
pour continuer à juguler ensemble la
poussée inflationniste qui même si elle
est moins forte en France qu'ailleurs
restent assez soutenu en matière
alimentaire et comme on dit nombre
d'entre vous frappent en réalité très
diverses citoyens à commencer par les
plus fragiles et
c'est donc un sujet sur lequel nous
continuons à travailler l'idée est assez
simple au même titre que je l'ai dit
d'abord les Français nos compatriotes
contribuent et pour certains voient la
hausse des prix et la paye l'État a pris
sa part je vais pas refaire le point sur
le bouclier tarifaire et l'ensemble des
aides je les fais juste avant mais juste
en 2023 c'est 46 milliards d'euros pour
vous donner une idée c'est plus que le
budget du ministère de la Défense et oui
effectivement au même titre que les
énergéticiens ont fait un effort si nous
arrivons à un prix à 280 euros le
mégawattheure sur les TPE et à réussir à
faire avancer le sujet avec les PME
c'est parce qu'ils ont contribué total
aussi le président de la République a
effectivement avec Bruno Le Maire
demandait au distributeur de faire un
effort et d'y contribuer en prenant sur
leur marge nous attendons donc nous
attendons donc des propositions dans les
prochains jours un objectif une solution
collective tous ensemble juste ou les
distributeurs raient sur leur marge et
non pas sur la marge de notre producteur
ou de la montre la chaîne et surtout une
solution rapide qui soit efficiente et
surtout opérationnelle pour les Français
dans les supermarchés dès l'arrivée du
printemps qui vous le savez arrive à la
fin mars nous sommes en train d'échanger
et nous continuerons à le faire dans les
prochains jours pour trouver une
solution qui accompagne nos compatriotes
durant les prochains mois
merci
la parole est maintenant madame Viviane
Artigalas pour le groupe socialiste pour
4 minutes
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues madame la ministre Bruno Le
Maire a dit la semaine dernière qu'il ne
croyait pas aux prévisions des
économistes qui estiment qu'il faut
s'attendre à un mois de mars rouge et à
une inflation qui dépasserait les 10%
sur les produits alimentaires il a dit
je le cite ce n'est pas la réalité alors
j'aimerais vous rappeler ce qu'est la
réalité quotidienne de plus en plus de
nos concitoyens depuis près d'un an les
prix à la consommation augmenter de 6% à
cause de l'inflation le nombre de
bénéficiaires de l'aide alimentaire à
augmenter de 10% en 2022 les retraités
et les étudiants sont touchés mais aussi
les personnes qui ont un emploi les prix
de l'énergie ont augmenté de 16% malgré
le bruit qu'il est arrivé et la remise à
la pompe dans les outre-mer l'inflation
et la forte dépendance de cette
territoire aux importations via
l'aviation et le fruit maritime se
répercute particulièrement sur le prix
des produits alimentaires dans ces
territoires également les mêmes
mécanismes en train de la même
conséquence sur les populations les plus
précaires il renforce le sentiment
prévenant d'une vie encore plus chère à
raison d'un coup de la vie déjà
supérieur à celui de la métropole et ça
aussi c'est la réalité cette hausse
globale des dépenses contraintes à un
impact direct sur la capacité des plus
modestes à se loger le nombre de ménages
en retard de paiement de loyer de plus
de 3 mois a augmenté de plus de 10% en
deux ans et la précarité dans le
logement c'est aussi la précarité
énergétique
5,6 millions de Français sont dans cette
situation et le chiffre ne baisse pas
avec la loi climat résilience le
gouvernement s'est fixé un objectif pour
objectif d'éradiquer les logements
énergivores d'ici 2028 or avec 37% de
passoire thermique occupé par des
minages vivants en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté avec un reste à charge
extrêmement important pour les familles
modestes avec une réelle difficulté
d'accès aux droits et aux aides
auxquelles elles ont droit faute d'un
accompagnement adéquat comment réussir à
atteindre un tel objectif nous formulons
inlassablement des propositions madame
la ministre dans le cadre des pochettes
de loi de finances successives par le
biais de propositions de loi
dernièrement avec mon collègue Rémy
Cardon nous avons déposé une PPL qui
propose de recentrer l'efforts
budgétaires du pays sur l'éradication
des passoires thermiques de mettre en
place un reste à charge zéro pour les
personnes les plus précaires et
d'assurer un égal accès au dispositif
d'accompagnement sur tous les
territoires y compris dans les zones peu
denses vos mesures vous les avez citées
elles contiennent certes l'inflation et
limite des hausses des prix de l'énergie
mais elles ne sont ni pérennes ni
structurelles et ne cible pas les
classes moyennes et populaires les plus
en difficulté elles sont donc incapables
de répondre à nos enjeux sur le long
terme vous ne pouvez pas dire qu'il n'y
aura pas de mars rouge les Français sont
déjà dans le rouge or pour lutter contre
conséquences de l'inflation il faut de
la cohérence et une véritable justice
sociale le forfait charge des aides au
logement doit être évalué le chèque
énergie doit attendre sa cible les
personnes chauffées en collectif comme
les locataires du parc social et les
copropriétaires ne peuvent y recourir
pour payer leur facture même constat
pour les personnes hébergées en foyer ou
en résidence sociale toutes ces
personnes sont éligibles mais ne peuvent
pas utiliser le chèque énergie comment
expliquer vous cette inégalité quand on
demande aux 5,6 millions de ménages en
situation de précarité énergétique donc
les plus exposées aux aléas climatiques
et à l'os des prix de l'énergie d'agir
pour la sobriété énergétique dans un but
de transition écologique on ne peut pas
leur reprocher d'éprouver un fort
sentiment d'injustice car ce sont eux
les moins favorisés qui sont les
premiers à payer la facture et il en
faut peu madame la ministre pour que ce
sentiment ne se transforme en colère
merci chers collègues
madame la ministre non
la parole est maintenant Monsieur Eric
Bocquet pour le groupe CRCE pour 5
minutes
je suis le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues dès le mois de
décembre 2020 les prix de l'énergie au
massivement augmenté plus 41% pour le
gaz entre décembre 2020 et octobre 2021
plus 21 % pour le carburant plus 4 %
pour l'électricité et la tendance c'est
bien sûr confirmée en 2022 l'envoler des
prix de l'énergie nous ayant entraîné
dans une spirale inflationniste
atteignant des niveaux records que nous
n'avions pas connu depuis les années 80
les options c'est à dire les produits
dérivés spéculatifs sur la matière
première avaient bondit de 158% dans la
même veine si l'invasion de l'Ukraine
par la Russie a bouleversé l'échelle de
distribution certaines entreprises
profitant de leur position dominante sur
les marchés ont spéculé sur les prix des
denrées alimentaires ou augmenter leur
marge dans certains cas mais tout cela
n'est pas vraiment nouveau cela fait
près de trois ans que nous vous alertons
que les associations vous alertent sur
la paupérisation croissante d'une partie
toujours plus importante de la
population du côté des PME même son de
cloche pour les entreprises du secteur
agroalimentaire c'est plus 29% pour le
coût des matières premières agricoles
par rapport à 2021 plus 26% pour le coût
des emballages carton et plastique plus
57 pour les coûts de l'énergie et ce
n'est pas fini la facture d'électricité
et de gaz va être multipliée par 3 dès
2023 par rapport à 2022 et par 5 par
rapport à 2021 voir davantage en ce sens
ce débat d'actualité n'en est pas 1
c'est un bilan des mesures prises par le
gouvernement pour tenter d'enrayer
l'inflation la spéculation et la perte
de pouvoir d'achat qui s'ensuit dont
nous avons besoin où est le choc
alimentaire a promis dès 2020 par le
Président de la République comment
expliquer que 50 % des personnes ayant
droit à l'indemnité carburant d'un
montant de 100 euros ne la demande pas
idem pour le chèque énergie côté aide
aux entreprises le bouclier tarifaire
exclut de nombreuses entreprises qui en
raison des équipements nécessaires à
leur activité possède un compteur
électrique dans la puissance est
supérieure à 36 kWh l'amortisseur
énergie se révèle également insuffisant
au regard de l'explosion cumulée des
prix des matières premières et des
produits énergétiques de plus la
complexité des différents dispositifs ne
permet pas aux bénéficiaires de s'en
saisir massivement alors oui comme le
solide de nombreux consommateurs le prix
des biens de première nécessité à moins
augmenter que dans d'autres pays en
France mais il a tout de même augmenté
dans des proportions sensibles alors que
de nombre ont mis en place des mesures
de revalorisation des salaires vous avez
préféré des mesures ponctuelles sans
porter générale vous continuez de
ménager le capital au détriment du
travail et pourtant la relégation de la
question des salaires en marge du débat
politique explique pour l'essentiel la
baisse de la qualité de vie de nos
concitoyens et de nos concitoyens ainsi
selon le CDE la France et le pays qui a
subi la plus forte baisse des revenus
réelle au deuxième trimestre 2022 là où
est la majorité des autres pays ont
progressé et paradoxalement alors que
les dividendes battent des records tous
les jours notre pays connaît une hausse
de la pauvreté inédite depuis de très
nombreuses années selon les mots
d'Olivier de chutter rapporteur spécial
de l'ONU manger à sa fin se chauffer se
soigner devrait être un droit
fondamental et une priorité politique
c'est la pauvreté qu'il vous faudrait
combattre cela vient un véritable
blocage et prise alimentaire via une
augmentation des salaires et des minima
sociaux via un tarif réglementé du gaz
et de l'électricité pour tous et la
sortie du marché européen de l'énergie
autant de mesures que nous portons dans
cette hémicycle de manière constante
merci
merci chers collègues madame la ministre
je vous en prie
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur Bocquet sans avoir l'espoir de
parvenir à vous convaincre j'ai quand
même à coeur de partager deux ou trois
points
deux trois choses déjà effectivement on
sera pas d'accord sur une chose
quand on est à 7,2 pour cent de taux de
chômage après 6 ans d'action résolues
quand on a un taux de chômage de nos
jeunes qui est le plus bas ou parmi les
plus bas en réalité le plus bas depuis
qu'on le mesure quand on a une
réindustrialisation de la France qui est
en cours ça prend du temps parce qu'on
parle de loin oui
quand on a 1725 décisions
d'investissement étrangers sur la seule
année 2022 permettant de créer ou de
maintenir plus de 58 000 emplois
industriels sur notre pays alors même
que ces emplois depuis 15 ans 20 ans
quitter le pays oui je vous répondrai
d'abord et avant tout mais j'ai à cœur
de parler des associations aussi que la
meilleure façon de faire en sorte qu'on
ait du pouvoir d'achat et qu'on puisse
s'en sortir d'ailleurs pas que pour des
raisons pécuniaires mais aussi pour des
raisons d'épanouissement personnel et je
sais que nous ne serons sûrement pas
d'accord c'est le travail le travail
c'est vers ça que quand j'avais toute
notre politique et notamment notre
politique fiscale l'allègement des
prélèvements sociaux nous n'avons pas
oublié et j'imagine que vous non plus la
baisse des cotisations sur les fiches de
paye qui a augmenté les salaires net en
2018 et ça aussi ça fait 6 ans qu'on se
bat pour que le travail paye mieux et
c'est à dire que nous ne faisons rien et
j'ai été en charge de l'économie sociale
et solidaire et j'ai trop de respect
pour les acteurs associatifs pour
laisser dire que nous ne faisons rien
dans le PLFR 2022 qui a été voté c'est
quasiment 60 millions d'euros pour les
associations hier encore le ministre
comble annonce 60 millions pour 2023
pour l'aide alimentaire de qualité je
passe les 27 appels à projets du plan de
relance dont j'ai eu l'honneur de parler
au banque alimentaire pour que l'État
tout au long de l'année 2020 et 2021
continuent à les soutenir financièrement
oui on se bat pour que les gens
travaillent et que le travail payent
mieux et oui on accompagne en même temps
celle ou ceux qui n'ayant pas de travail
ont besoin de la solidarité nationale
j'avais à cœur de le rappeler je vous
remercie merci Monsieur Bocquet non la
parole est maintenant monsieur le
questeur Vincent capocanellase pour le
groupe Union centriste pour 8 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues rarement un débat
sera autant tomber à point si nous
devions nous interroger sur l'intérêt
des débats d'actualité nous aurions sans
doute la réponse aujourd'hui à quelques
heures de la fin des négociations
commerciales la grande distribution les
agriculteurs les industriels le
gouvernement se renvoie la balle sur une
hausse à venir de 10% des prix
alimentaires
des chiffres filtres 25% d'augmentation
éventuelle pour les boîtes de Nesquik 10
% auraient dit Coca-Cola 17% pardon si
l'inflation ralentit et si nous avons
jusque là évité c'est fort bien la
boucle pris sa salaire la hausse des
prix alimentaires est elle plus
alarmante et même si nous essayons de
faire la part des choses on ne peut
qu'être inquiet bien sûr
6,2% d'inflation en France c'est mieux
que 8 et demi dans l'ensemble de l'Union
européenne bien sûr le gouvernement a su
mettre en place un certain nombre de
mesures ça a été rappelé pour soutenir
le pouvoir d'achat tel que la remise
carburant l'indemnité inflation le
chèque énergie le bouclier tarifaire sur
le gaz électricité ou encore des aides
ciblées pour les ménages et bien sûr les
entreprises mais hier mardi nous avons
connu l'inflation alimentaire de février
sur un an à savoir
14,5%. et le constat est simple les prix
des darrés alimentaires évoluent de
manière beaucoup plus forte que
l'inflation
et ce qui filtre des discussions en
cours laisse entrevoir des hausses
élevés sans doute de même niveau le
président Système U a parlé de 10% le
président de Carrefour a été plus
alarmant encore
l'addition des 14,4% déjà constatés avec
la hausse attendue disons de l'ordre de
10% si elle devait se confirmer fait
froid dans le dos il y a bien sûr une
part de bras de fer dans ce face à face
annuel entre
chacun des acteurs de la distribution
mais tout cela quand même pose question
les distributeurs accueillent des
transformateurs qui désigne du doigt les
prix des matières premières voire les
agriculteurs le gouvernement demande aux
grandes surfaces de réduire leur marge
il évoque un panier un chariot de prix
alimentaire
qui devrait être maintenu sous contrôle
et vous ne direz peut-être madame
analyse tout à l'heure où vous en êtes
de ces discussions étaient dispositifs
vous pensez pouvoir mettre en oeuvre on
peine à expliquer totalement ces
augmentations l'année dernière la guerre
en Ukraine les prix l'énergie et les
matières premières se les transports se
des produits manif facturés pouvaient
expliquer l'inflation alimentaire mais
en 2023 ces chiffres sont bien moindres
bien sûr le niveau des prix de
production
relais peu à peu l'inflation déjà
constatée et se diffuse l'inflation des
prix de production serait de 17% ce
chiffre demeurant élevé est inférieur à
celui qui existe dans le reste de
l'Union européenne faut-il y voir l'une
des causes des augmentations attendues
quoi qu'il en soit si le pouvoir d'achat
a pu être préservé en 2020 et 21
il a baissé de 0,2% en 2022 et nous
risquons de perdre cette acquis en 2023
il est vrai qu'en 2022 les salaires ont
augmenté de 4,2% en moyenne et
l'inflation de 6 le niveau des prix va
être supérieur dans son évolution au
niveau des salaires les aides de l'État
et les primes ne pouvant rester élevés
le moral des ménages est un niveau qui
devient plus faible le sujet est que les
salaires augmentent moins vite que
l'inflation et que la consommation s'en
trouve affectée alors que c'était jusque
là un des moteurs de notre économie
sur ce point il nous faut peut-être voir
comment l'avenir peut-être construit la
soutenabilité notre budget nous appelle
bien sûr à la plus grande vigilance et
c'est toute la quadrature du cercle elle
suppose cette soutenabilité un effort
collectif reposant sur la maîtrise de la
dépense qui doit être couplée à la
recherche d'une plus grande efficacité
de celle-ci
il y a bien sûr une contradiction dont
il ne faut essayer de sortir la
croissance la maîtrise de l'inflation
sont de ce point de vue là des
nécessités
peut-être nous direz-vous comment vous
voyez les choses sur ce plan là
d'ici là il faut sans doute répondre de
manière segmentée à un certain nombre
d'urgences
observatoire français des conjonctures
économiques a publié une étude certains
l'ont rappelé sur les mesures
budgétaires importantes qui ont été
mises en place et sur leur effet sur le
pouvoir d'achat les Français en 2022 et
2023 il estime qu'en 2023 le pouvoir
d'achat pourrait revenir à son niveau
d'avant la crise sanitaire fin 2019 il
se réduire de 1,2% à 2%. entre la fin
2021 et la fin 2023 bien sûr sans les
mesures prises observatoires estiment
que la baisse de pouvoir d'achat entre
fin 2021 et fin 2023 toujours aurait pu
atteindre 5%. tout l'efficacité des
mesures ont été mises en oeuvre et il
est vrai que le bouclier du tarifaire la
remise carburant on semble-t-il permis
de soutenir le pouvoir d'achat en
moyenne à hauteur de 790 euros en 2022
et aussi de soutenir le niveau de vie
des ménages les plus modestes de 5,1% et
j'ai noté que pour les ménages les plus
aisés c'était de 2,2%
. si l'impact de l'inflation sur les
ménages touchent les Français il le fait
de façon inégale en fonction de leurs
revenus de leur situation personnelle et
de leur lieu de vie selon les travaux
l'OSCE encore les ménages ruraux se
éloignés des centres urbains et les plus
modestes seraient les plus touchés par
ce phénomène inflationniste
je voudrais rajouter un élément
l'envoler des taux d'intérêt affecte la
capacité des ménages notamment les
primo-accédants à devenir propriétaire
si je crois une grande difficulté
beaucoup de
primo-accédants potentiels sortent du
marché et on a là un point d'alarme tant
pour le secteur immobilier et la
construction que bien sûr et avant tout
pour ceux qui veulent accéder à la
propriété pour les accidents je crois
protéger proroger le PTZ dispositif cœur
du soutien la propriété serait
particulièrement utile dans un contexte
de hausse des taux et peut-être faut-il
réfléchir aussi à développer massivement
le bail réel solidaire notamment pour
les jeunes ménages ça serait me
semble-t-il des mesures utiles et en
tout cas il y a un sujet sur la sherté
du logement et la difficulté d'accession
comme le logement pèse dans le budget
des ménages pour une part importante
aussi pour les locataires ou futurs
locataires du parc social il y a sans
doute aussi une réflexion à conduire
pour permettre parfois des loyers plus
adaptés nous mesurons madame la ministre
l'emploi des difficultés l'effort qui a
déjà été réalisé nous avons ici une
pleine conscience des contraintes
budgétaires mais les mesures que le
Gouvernement doit semble-t-il annoncer
sont pour beaucoup une question de vie
quotidienne et même d'urgence je vous
remercie merci Monsieur le casteur
madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Kester d'abord merci de la
précision étayée de vos chiffres et de
vos sources
c'est vrai que dans ces débats et vous
avez été nombreux à le dire d'ailleurs
peu importe les bancs le débat mais je
suis pas étonné tombe à point nommer il
vous a pas échappé mais comme vous
l'avez mentionné je vais le préciser que
je ne me suis pas
caché derrière des chiffres macros et
que je reconnais la réalité de
l'inflation et de l'inflation
alimentaire ressentie par nos
compatriotes et ayant en charge les PME
mais aussi la consommation c'est à
l'aune de cette inflation ressentie que
je raisonne je voulais juste pourquoi
roborer vos propos rappeler l'Insee pas
plus tard qu'hier a rappelé qu'au total
sur l'année 2022 le pouvoir d'achat et
globalement préservé il ne faudrait pas
oublier de prendre en compte ce que vous
avez fait l'ensemble des mesures
notamment les chèques énergie ainsi le
pouvoir d'achat dit ajuster progresse
même de 1,2% en 2022 j'en profite aussi
pour répondre indirectement au sénateur
babary les bonnes nouvelles sont rares
le taux de marge de nos entreprises
progresse aussi sur le quatrième
trimestre et s'établir moyenne à 32% en
2022 il baisse un peu par rapport à 2021
qui était une année particulière mais il
est quand même au dessus de son niveau
de 2018 de 0,5 points c'est-à-dire qu'on
sort après la crise sanitaire on est
aujourd'hui dans une crise
inflationniste et nous avons des
entreprises dont le taux de marge quoi
qu'il advienne étant une augmentation
vous m'avez demandé en un mot aussi où
nous en étions côté grande distribution
et à la suite des travaux que nous
menons je le redis suite à l'annonce à
la demande du Président de la République
nous travaillons d'arrache-pied avec
Bruno Le Maire pour embarquer les
distributeurs à nos côtés mettre en
place une solution collective rapide
juste j'ai proposé une idée c'est une
sorte de mise de jeu je n'ai jamais dit
que c'était la seule solution et j'ai
encore moins dit qu'elle était parfaite
elle a le mérite d'exister de pouvoir
être critiqué de pouvoir être soutenu
j'attends et Bruno Le Maire de contre
propositions dans les jours qui viennent
et bien l'objectifs à la caisse je vous
remercie monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur le testeur pas de réponse
dernier orateur inscrit monsieur le
Président Patrick Kanner pour le groupe
socialiste pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
ce matin j'ai écouté une chaîne de
télévision continue et qui titrée
inflation marche le mois de tous les
dangers je vous ai aussi écouté madame
sur une grande chaîne publique ce matin
vous voyez c'est important ça se met de
bonne humeur
en novembre dernier
lors d'une audition par la commission
des affaires économiques monsieur le
ministre de l'économie avait confirmé
ces déclarations précédentes et a
indiqué que l'inflation que nous
subissions n'était que transitoire et
qu'une baisse des prix interviendrait à
partir de fin 2022
nous sommes dans le premier trimestre
2023 et cette baisse des prix n'est pas
intervenue alors oui pour certains trois
mois c'est peu de choses mais pour ceux
qui éprouvent des difficultés
financières c'est une éternité on le
sait aujourd'hui cette inflation sera
pérenne les estimations portent plutôt
sur une stabilisation d'ici 2025 mais de
quoi parle-nous finalement en 2025
inflation nulle inflation 2 3%, comment
vont évoluer les taux d'intérêts quelle
politique sera menée par la BCE personne
ne peut le dire au vu de la vitesse à
laquelle évolue l'économie mondiale et
je crois qu'on a intérêt à se méfier des
estimations de et la sagesse qui
commanderait à relativiser toutes les
prévisions que nous pourrions faire il
faut donc avoir en tête que
malheureusement les épisodes de choc
économiques que nous avons connu
notamment avec la covid seront amenés à
se répéter à devenir de plus en plus
fréquent les prévisions donc peuvent
être faussées mes chers collègues
l'objet du débat d'aujourd'hui porte sur
les conséquences de cette inflation sur
le pouvoir d'achat des Français et en
particulier des plus modestes de nos
concitoyens or malgré le courrier que
madame la Première ministre a pu
m'envoyer il y a quelques semaines je
reste persuadé que les difficultés
éprouvées par les foyers français sont
plaignantes et je reste mobilisé pour
lutter contre la précarisation avec mes
collègues du groupe socialiste
écologiste républicains contre la fin
des mois difficiles contre toutes ces
trappes à pauvreté que ce gouvernement
madame la ministre continue de ne pas
voir c'est d'ailleurs pour cela que
notre groupe a proposé la tenue de ce
débat et je me suis heureux de voir que
Monsieur lacher ait pu le retenir dans
ce voilà dans ce contexte qu'on appelle
maintenant les débats d'actualité du
premier mercredi de chaque mois
il est important de continuer à porter
ces sujets au sein du débat national il
est important de continuer à être les
porte-voix des concitoyens les plus
modestes madame la ministre aucune prime
aucun chèque ne remplacera une hausse
juste et durable des revenus pour
maintenir et seulement maintenir le
pouvoir d'achat car non madame la
ministre l'augmentation du SMIC de 8% et
les aides ponctuelles mises en place par
votre gouvernement ne suffisent pas à
compenser la véritable déflagration
économique que certains foyers ont pu
subir et continuer à subir par ailleurs
l'obsession du dogmatisme moins d'impôts
que vous vous évertuez à ériger comme
solution à tous les problèmes ne semble
pas approprié à ce contexte en fait en
termes de ruissellement c'est celui de
la précarité que nous connaissons de
plus en plus la ministre les mesures que
vous avez pu prendre en faveur du
pouvoir d'achat existe nous
reconnaissons pour autant les coupes
budgétaires que vous avez pu opérer
pèsent également sur le budget des
Français les plus modestes je pense bien
sûr symboliquement à cette baisse de 5
euros décidez au début du quinquennat
précédent sur les aides au logement
ce qu'il faut offenser ce ne sont pas
des chèques énergie des chèques
carburants ou des chèques de rentrée ce
qui leur faut c'est une revalorisation
des salaires
le groupe socialiste écologiste
républicain d'ailleurs rédigé une
proposition de résolution demandant que
soit tenu un Grenelle des salaires en
France à l'initiative de notre collègue
Thierry Cosic ce qui leur faut c'est
mettre fin au désarmement fiscal du pays
pour rappel la politique mise en œuvre
par votre gouvernement entraînera une
perte de 500 milliards d'euros de
recettes fiscales entre 2017 et 2027 ce
qui leur faut français c'est une
répartition des richesses dans les
entreprises prospère qui soient juste
nous vous avons proposé le taxer les
super profits nous avons été soutenu par
des millions de Français
ou y compris même par des collègues
parlementaires
issus du centre vous nous avez pas là
non plus entendu il y a quelques jours
étaient confirmé des dividendes qui
atteignent des records 140 milliards
cette situation n'est pas juste et
devient insupportable il demandait à
tous les Français de fournir un effort
et on va y venir dans quelques heures
sur le débat concernant les retraites la
décence serait de demander le même
effort à tous nos concitoyens y compris
ceux qui ont le plus bénéficié de
l'hyper bouclier fiscale depuis
maintenant bientôt 6 ans nos concitoyens
que nous voulons aider Madame ministre
ce ne sont pas les plus riches vous
l'avez compris mais ceux qui aujourd'hui
font exploser les chiffres des
restaurants du corps du cœur dans notre
pays dans la ministre ce qu'il faut aux
Français je termine là-dessus monsieur
le Président je ne sont pas des mesures
ponctuelles ce qui leur faut c'est une
réelle redistribution sinon attention
danger le désespoir est source de toutes
les colères
je vous remercie
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président
kaner
décembre noire juillet vert marce rouge
Dieu sait si j'aime la peinture mais je
ne crois pas qu'il relève d'un membre
d'une équipe de gouvernement de choisir
le pinôme des difficultés qui sont
devant nous et en ça je comprends tout à
fait la position que je partage si tant
est que vous en doutiez de mon ministre
du tutelle Bruno Le Maire sur le fait
que l'inflation va demeurer soutenue est
soutenu et va demeurer soutenu sur le
fait et nous serons d'accord là dessus
monsieur le Président Kanner vous avez
parlé de choc qu'effectivement nous
sommes face à un choc inflationniste et
sur le fait qu'il est indispensable
qu'en plus que de ce que nous faisons
depuis maintenant 6 ans nous continuons
à essayer de faire plus c'est bien pour
ça que nous demandons en responsabilité
aux acteurs économiques aujourd'hui de
faire un effort sur le choc
inflationniste d'ailleurs là aussi
je serai plutôt d'accord avec vous je ne
suis pas devant je ne saurai mentionner
d'ailleurs ni précisément son début et
encore moins sa fin ce que je sais
mentionner c'est ce que j'essaye
modestement de faire au nom du
gouvernement pour accompagner les
Français vous dites nous sommes les
portes voies des plus modestes je vais
pas revenir j'ai peu de temps mais à
défaut de je sais pas si c'est des
porte-paroles ou des porte-voix en tout
cas c'est des portactions que vous avez
au sein du gouvernement nous n'avons pas
trembler quand il a fallu augmenter les
minimas sociaux nous n'avons pas trembé
je l'ai dit tout à l'heure pour les 5,7
millions de fonctionnaires dont le point
d'indice a été revalorisé des juillet
avec la plus forte hausse depuis 37 ans
j'ai donné un exemple mais je voudrais
en donner un autre c'est pour
l'illustrer un gain de plus de 1093
euros net annuel pour l'infirmiers
anesthésiste avec 8 ans d'ancienneté
nous avons effectivement revalorisé
aussi la prime d'activité à plus de 4%,
vous appelez de vos vœux une conférence
sur les salaires je l'entends bien je
rappellerai mais je sais que vous le
savez puisque je vous respecte monsieur
le Président kaner que jusqu'à preuve du
contraire l'État ne fixe pas les
salaires et c'est très bien comme ça je
vous remercie merci madame monsieur le
Président de canner non madame la
ministre il vous revient de conclure si
vous le souhaitez pour 5 minutes
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs d'abord merci
pour ce débat cet échange qui malgré nos
divergences pointent je pense le sujet
de préoccupation de nos compatriotes et
on ça un débat qui me semble absolument
indispensable à avoir ensemble de mon
côté j'ai essayé de vous faire part du
fait qu'indépendamment du choc
inflationniste nous menons depuis
maintenant 6 ans une action résolue pour
accompagner le pouvoir d'achat des
Français pour revaloriser le travail
j'entends aussi avec beaucoup d'humilité
que toutes ces solutions en tout cas
pour certains vous paraissent largement
insuffisantes on se les dit mais je
pense important de le rappeler même si
c'est compliqué et que le ressenti est
majeur il faudrait quand même pas
oublier que nous demeurons 13 ans de ça
de l'inflation que subissent nos voisins
européens et que là encore
le hasard est un concept mais c'est
aussi possible le fruit de politique
résolu depuis 6 ans après j'ai envie
d'être assez clair et dans le cadre du
respect que je porte à la Chambre haute
évidemment et c'est à dire que nous en
faisons assez non parce qu'en réalité on
en fera jamais assez pour revaloriser le
pouvoir d'achat de nos concitoyens on en
fera jamais assez contre l'inflation et
notamment l'inflation alimentaire pour
les plus fragiles et donc on doit en
humilité continuer à proposer des
solutions on doit aussi faire attention
j'ai bien entendu notamment du président
canner dont je connais l'expérience les
propositions en matière de salaire
attention à l'alimentation de la spirale
inflationniste à laquelle certains pays
européens ont cédé et qui conduiraient
par exemple possiblement comme l'ont
fait les Belges une à une indexation de
tous les salaires sur l'inflation je
n'oublie pas que les Belges ont une
indexation des salaires sur l'inflation
mais non pas de bouclier tarifaire et je
sais que vous êtes nombreux à raisonner
dans le contexte contraint que
connaissent nos finances publiques avec
des taux d'intérêt qui désormais
dépassent les 3,14% puisque l'inflation
a aussi la Bourse de Paris hier la
démontrer des conséquences directes sur
la crédibilité financière de la
signature française à côté des mesures
financières que nous avons prises je
veux aussi vous dire que nous prenons
des mesures qui peuvent paraître pas ici
mais parfois dans les débats secondaires
pour certains mais qui ne le sont pas je
veux aussi vous rappeler avec la loi
pouvoir d'achat et notamment les apports
des sénateurs que nous avons aussi
amélioré le pouvoir du choix de nos
compatriotes quand ils veulent se
dégager d'un abonnement quand ils
veulent arrêter de payer des abonnements
et qui souhaitent les résilier
facilement c'est le cas aussi au delà du
gaz de l'électricité des magazines et
d'Internet pour les assurances et les
mutuelles et d'ici trois mois au plus
tard au 1er juin 2023 l'ensemble des
vendeurs est assureurs devront prévoir
un bouton résiliation en ligne facile
d'accès la résiliation des abonnements
la facilitation et le dégagement par les
consommateurs de ces engagements peut
aussi permettre plus facilement de
retrouver un peu de respiration
financière vous dire aussi pour terminer
que j'ai d'abord à cœur la mission que
j'ai eu pendant quasiment deux ans au
service de l'économie sociale et
solidaire que vous avez été nombreux
notamment sur la gauche de l'émission à
rappeler la situation d'un certain
nombre de nos compatriotes très
fragilisés par la crise vous dire que au
même titre que nous avons été là avec
des montants historiques dans une
situation très compliquée et notamment
via le plan de relance au côté des
Banques Alimentaires le ministre combe a
aussi annoncé hier une mobilisation de
60 millions d'euros à l'endroit des
banques alimentaires et sachez
pour être très direct que la première
ministre n'hésitera pas s'il faut faire
plus pour accompagner nos associations
qui accompagnent les plus fragiles pour
ce qui est de ce débat je vous en
remercie et j'espère que j'aurai
prochainement le plaisir de rééchanger
avec vous sur ces sujets pour se battre
ensemble pour faire baisser et contenir
l'inflation que subissent nos
compatriotes inflation forte mais
inflation qu'il convient quand même de
rappeler qui est bien moins forte que
celle de nos voisins européens je ne
sais pas si quand on sera on se compare
on se rassure ou on se désole en tout
cas comme le disait Michelet c'est quand
on se résigne que tout est perdu et
comptez sur moi je suis pas prête de me
résigner je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre
le premier débat est donc clos avant de
passer au deuxième point l'ordre du jour
je vais donner la parole à Monsieur le
testeur Vincent capo canelas pour une
mise au point merci monsieur le
Président chouette procéder à une
rectification concernant le vote de mon
collègue Hervé Moret sur le scrutin
numéro 134 du 14 février 2023 ce vote
concerné l'amendement 5 rectifié bis
présenté par Monsieur Stéphane sotarel
tendant insérer un article additionnel
après l'article 4 terres
il s'agissait d'une proposition de loi
portant amélioration d'accès aux soins
par la confiance au professeur de santé
monsieur Moret souhaité voter pour et
non contre donc pour l'adoption de cet
amendement je vous remercie si Monsieur
le testeur acte est donné de votre mise
au point de figurat dans l'analyse
politique du scrutin concerné
changement d'équipe bonjour madame la
ministre ah bah oui ah oui il faut
partir même d'ici je sais et oui